the World Health Organization put out
questionable guidance on how to deal
with the corona virus it was slow to
communicate the magnitude of the threat
and at whitewashed the Chinese
government's early handling of the
crisis it destroyed much of its
credibility damaged the field of Public
Health and failed to contain the
pandemic no is not the time that's a bit
too early to consider that this event is
a public health emergency of
international concern
wh o--'s response in part stems from its
overly deferential stance towards China
which is its second biggest contributor
among 194 member states a phenomenal
collective action and cooperation by the
people of China to this response would
have seen many more cases outside China
by now efforts to protect their own
people and the people of the world the
Chinese government is to be
congratulated for the extraordinary
measures it has taken to contain the
outbreak whi whitewashed the
authoritarian governments overall record
it praised China for releasing the
virus's genome while neglecting to
mention that it took them at least 17
days to do so it didn't report human to
human transmission until late January
even though Chinese doctors suspected at
at least a month earlier although the
extreme lockdown of Wuhan likely did
save thousands of lives wh o scientists
weren't allowed into Wuhan until three
weeks after the outbreak first came to
light
meanwhile the waho praised the Chinese
for their openness China took action
massively at the epicenter and that
helped in preventing cases from being
exported if we say there's a pandemic of
coronavirus we're essentially accepting
that every human on the planet will be
exposed to that virus and China have
clearly shown that that's not
necessarily the natural outcome of this
event as the virus continued spreading
across Europe and reached America w-h-o
recommended that the travel industry
maintained the stat
well there is no reason for measures
that unnecessarily interfere with
international travel and trade one
country that ignored this advice was
Taiwan which also warned the w-h-o that
it suspected the virus was spreading
through human to human transmission and
was ignored Taiwan which has one of the
lowest rates of known kovat infections
per capita among countries impacted by
the virus was prevented from joining the
w-h-o as a member country in 2015 by
China which refuses to acknowledge its
independence in late March World Health
Organization epidemiologist Bruce
Aylward declined to answer a Hong Kong
reporter's question about Taiwan or even
acknowledge its existence with the WTO
consider Taiwan's membership
hello I couldn't hear your question okay
yeah I mean that let me let me repeat
the question right like this because I'm
I'm actually curious on talking about
Taiwan as well on Taiwan's case we
decided to give dr. Albert another call
to follow up and I just want to see if
you can comment a bit on how Chi Hwan
has done so far in terms of containing
the virus well we've already talked
about China and you know when you look
across all the different areas of China
they've actually all done quite a good
job so with that and I'd like to thank
you very much for inviting us to
participate as Taiwan was distributing
face masks to its citizens the whu-oh
was advising the rest of the world that
they were unnecessary and initially the
CDC and US Surgeon General followed its
lead mask should only be used by
healthcare workers caretakers or by
people who are sick with symptoms of
fever and cough if you do not have these
symptoms you do not have to wear masks
because there is no evidence that they
protect people who are not sick but
health experts pointed to mounting
evidence that masks can help slow the
spread of respiratory diseases
especially among asymptomatic carriers a
population that the w-h-o maintains is
virtually non-existent despite mounting
evidence to the contrary in mid-february
the w-h-o trumpeted good news from China
China continued to show a decline in new
confirmed cases once again encouraged by
this trend ignoring evidence that it may
have been a statistical anomaly and US
intelligence believes that China has
entirely misrepresented both case
numbers and death tolls according to
Bloomberg News finally on March 11th
after Italy was already in full national
lockdown with more than 10,000 cases
w-h-o finally acknowledged the true
magnitude of the crisis declaring a
global pandemic corvid 19 can be
characterized as a pandemic
they could have called it months earlier
they should have known and they probably
didn't know so we'll be looking into
that very carefully and we're gonna put
a hold on money spent to the w-h-o
Donald Trump and other world leaders
aren't absolved for their failures by
the wh o--'s bungling of this crisis but
it's important to remember that if the
World Health Organization had done its
job
the nightmare were living through might
not have happened at all